So Leute, moin, oh Moment, ich muss mal kurz das Headset entwirren.
So, der Chat ist aber heute wieder besonders.
Ich hab letztens ne richtig nice Corona-Map gefunden, aber ich, Corona-Life-Map oder so,
das war richtig...
Aber irgendwie, ich hab mir das nicht gespeichert, jetzt find ich den Kram nicht mehr.
Das war noch so ne Map, die war in dunkel und in rot.
Das sah also richtig, dann richtig Mocker-S-mäßig aus.
War das das, ich, das...
Ja, genau, die ist es.
Woher, der Gamer Maxis, der weiß Bescheid, die meine ich.
Ja, wo, wo, wo ist, wo ist Germany?
Was, Germany?
Das sind aber die gleichen Daten, das zeigt nicht an wo in Germany.
Ja.
Äh...
Also ich will ja der Map jetzt nicht irgendwie zu nahe treten, aber geografisch ist das nicht
ganz korrekt.
Stimmen denn die anderen Sachen wenigstens, ja, Italy, ja, Italy stimmt, France, wenn
das die Franzosen hören würden, hier in Polen, Frankreich in Polen, die Map ist ein bisschen
fail.
Stimmt es, wenn man hier klickt überhaupt?
Ah ja, hier stimmt es, hier stimmt es, ok.
Na gut, so genug Monka Corona.
Der hat es ja letzte Woche im Hals gekratzt, ne, aber ist, ist, ist wieder weg.
Letzte Woche, Mittwoch, als mir, als mir, wie wenn man halt bisschen Erkältung kriegt,
hat es mir angefangen im Hals zu kratzen und da habe ich meinen Chef gefragt, hier was
soll ich ihm machen?
Du hast ja gesagt, wenn, wenn man auch irgendwie nur irgendwelche Anzeichen hat, soll man nicht
auf die Arbeit kommen, habe ich ihn gefragt, was soll ich machen, habe ich gesagt, Max
bleib daheim, komm bloß nicht her, habe ich mir gedacht, alles klar, wird gemacht.
Das heißt, ich hatte jetzt, ich habe jetzt Donnerstag, Freitag Homeoffice gemacht und
das witzige ist, ich habe um fünf Ecken gehört, also quasi, ich kenne einen, der einen kennt,
der mit einer aus der Personalabteilung und aus dem, aus unserem Beratungsdingskomitee
einen kennt, die gesagt hat, dass die Firma, wo ich arbeite, plant, ab nächster Woche
quasi komplett auf Homeoffice umzustellen.
Also das heißt, es kann durchaus sein, dass ich jetzt gezwungen werde Homeoffice zu machen.
Was mich nicht wirklich stört, weil ich mein, dann kann ich eineinhalb Stunden länger pennen.
Tja, so, genug Corona.
Mir ist mal aufgefallen, dass meine Twitter-Media-Timeline aus, quasi komplett, nur aus irgendwelchen
Twitch-Emojis und Memepilchen besteht, guckt euch das mal an, das ist doch nicht normal.
Oh Gott, man geht natürlich nicht, kann man hier rückwärts, so, Kokona, KegW, MonkaS,
Tepehands, Facepalm, richtig, Monka, Corona, MonkaS, oh ja, mein Werkzeugkasten erneut,
ja, Fivehead, MonkaS, also im Prinzip ist alles meine komplette Twitter-Timeline und
besteht nur aus so einem Blödsinn, oder?
Du wurdest heute auf Corona getestet und Kirolo sagt, hey Max, wie hast du für dich deine
Traumberuf gefunden?
Nee, gelernt habe ich ja mal Fach Informatiker-System, boah, wenn man, wenn man, wenn man, ach du
Scheiße, ich kann nicht schreiben, Fach Informatiker-System, das habe ich ja mal gelernt, ich, ich würde
aber nicht so weit gehen und sagen, mir war klar, dass, dass, dass, wenn ich das lerne,
dass, sag mal, bin ich heute irgendwie lauter?
WTF?
Hä, Windows, was, ich bin lauter als, what the fuck, irgendwie kommt das, sag mal, ich
hab das, ich hab das doch nie auf volle Pulle stehen, oder?
Warum hat sich das denn jetzt auf volle Pulle geschaltet?
WTF, was ist da, so, Moment mal, Leute, da muss ich mal kurz gucken, ich muss mal kurz
meinen, man sieht ja immer, ich kann ja immer schreiben, man sieht ja immer meine Settings
kurz am Anfang vom Stream, ich muss jetzt mal echt im letzten, im letzten Stream nachgucken,
was ich da hatte.
Okay, wo sieht man, wo, wo sieht man irgendwo meine OBS, irgendwo sieht man doch hier bestimmt
meine OBS, hier, boah, hier, doch, aber vielleicht, vielleicht war's da, vielleicht war's da
schon kaputt.
Ach, keine Ahnung, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß wieder mal nicht, was mit Windows los
ist.
Ich mein, allein schon, wenn ich, warum, ich mein, warum verstellen Windows die Sound-Settings
einfach so, ist doch nicht, als hätte ich irgendwas gemacht, so, hier Sound, äh, bock,
ich kann mir immer noch nicht mal merken, wie man hier auf die Settings kommt, Sound-Control-Panel,
Recording-Microphone-Levels, 91, ja, keine Ahnung, warum das so laut ist, aber, aber
jetzt passt, oder, jetzt ist, jetzt ist ja wieder, jetzt ist wieder ganz okay, denke
ich.
Jetzt bin ich etwas zu, nee, ich müsste eigentlich richtig gut sein, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin
kurz vor zu laut, also ich bin auf jeden Fall jetzt sogar ein Stückchen lauter als sonst,
ja, minimal, minimal, aber ungefähr so wie sonst, aber warum Windows den Crap immer
verstellt, ist es mir vollkommen schleierhaft, warum, was da dran so schwierig ist, einfach
mal, äh, Audio-Settings beizubehalten, äh, bin ich irgendwie übersteuert oder so, muss
ich gerade mal ausprobieren, bin ich irgendwie übersteuert, bin ich irgendwie übersteuert,
nee, bin ich nicht, okay, passt, alles gut, ey, ich, ich, ich weiß echt nicht, was Microsoft
da treibt, ja, hier ist auch der Gain voll hoch, den hab ich ja so eingestellt, aber
ich weiß, ja, scheiß egal, wir machen jetzt weiter, also, ähm, mein Desktop ist aufgeräumt,
ja, da ist der Trans-Schuld, da ist der Chat Trans-Schuld, weil ich immer so viele E-Mails
senden muss und so geht es uns, ja, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht, what the fuck, was ist das,
Arbeitsein, Atmosphäre, so, so, was, so, was ist denn das, echt alles.
Keine Ahnung, was die da treiben.
Ich mein, warum ist das eben einfach angegangen?
Ah, gut. Also Leute, wenn irgendwie die Soundsettings abkacken, müssten wir Bescheid sagen.
Ähm, genau, also es kam irgendwie die Frage, wie ich meinen Traumberuf gefunden habe.
Also wie gesagt, ursprünglich habe ich mal sowas hier gelernt, bei einem Internetprovider.
Jetzt kann ich auch ein bisschen das Mikrofon wegmachen, dann passt es, glaube ich, besser.
Also ursprünglich habe ich das mal bei einem Internetprovider gelernt. So, hier drei Jahre.
Aber mir war damals nicht klar, wo ich jetzt lande. Also das war mehr oder weniger Glück.
Und natürlich ist man auch ein bisschen selber da gefordert oder ist man selbst ja irgendwie auch mit ein bisschen dafür verantwortlich, was man so macht.
Also wenn das nicht ist, was einem gefällt, dann muss man halt gucken, dass man irgendwas anderes macht.
Also im Endeffekt, nur weil man die Ausbildung gemacht hat, sagt ja gar nichts aus, im Endeffekt.
Ihr müsst mal bei Amazon gucken, Leute.
Oh, oh, wir haben, ich hab Saps verpasst. Ihr müsst mal bei Amazon gucken nach Klopapier.
Und ihr werdet feststellen, es ist alles ausverkauft. Komplettes Klopapier ist ausverkauft.
Die Leute kaufen Klopapier, wie verrückt.
Du musst mal kurz die Saps gucken, weil das habe ich jetzt voll verdrängt.
Warum geht da Sound im An und Aus dazwischen?
What the fuck, Windows, please.
Wir machen jetzt mal was anderes. Wir machen jetzt mal was anderes. Wir machen jetzt Sound-Control.
Sound-Control. So, ich hab keine Ahnung, auf was ich das runterstellen muss. Ich stell das jetzt einfach mal runter.
Ich mach hier volle Pulle. So, jetzt bin ich natürlich zu laut.
Und hier mach ich runter. Irgendwie, ich glaube sonst hatte ich irgendwie was um 70. Hab ich jetzt einfach so...
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal, dass ich irgendwas um 70 hatte sonst hier. 70, 71, 73 oder so.
So, und jetzt, jetzt, jetzt müsste es ungefähr so sein. Soll es sein wie sonst auch immer.
So, also. Was wollte ich jetzt gerade noch sagen? Genau. Also, gesubbt haben heute, wen haben wir hier am Start?
Chris Downhench resubs 6 Monate. Danke schön. Hi IQ Sub. Genauso von Ideas. Resubs gerade für 2 Monate.
Du bist aber schon länger am Start. Der Name sagt mir irgendwas. Der kommt mir überkannt vor.
Ja, und es ist geil. Es ist alles ausverkauft, ne?
Also, die Leute drehen echt voll am Rad. So, also was wir heute machen. Ich hab nämlich vorhin ein Video gesehen auf YouTube.
GitHub Actions auf irgendeiner Developer Konferenz. Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Ich glaube, ich glaube das hier ist auch egal. Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass anscheinend GitHub schon länger eine Möglichkeit hat, quasi pro repo eigene Build Skripte laufen zu lassen.
Oder so in der Richtung sowas jetzt. Ich weiß nicht genau wie es funktioniert und was es ist. Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Das ist natürlich schon ziemlich praktisch. Mal angenommen.
Heute hab ich mal einen Server erstellt hier bei Digital Ocean. Geht nur mit SSH Keylogin.
Ich hab mal einen Server erstellt bei Digital Ocean mit dem tollen Namen Ubuntu. Da freut sich der Chat, dachte ich mir, wenn ich das Ding so nenne.
Und was wir heute mal ausprobieren wollen ist oder werden ist, ich hab auf GitHub einen Repo angelegt.
Ja, Wattu. Ich hab auf GitHub einen Repo angelegt, nämlich hier das Action-Test-Repo.
Da ist noch nichts drin. Und da legen wir einfach mal eine HelloWorld-ASP.NET, irgendeine Web-Anwendung legen wir mal da drin an.
Und dann probieren wir mal mit GitHub Actions bei jedem Push in das Repo die Anwendung zu bauen und irgendwie auf den Server zu kopieren.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert. An sich, wenn das funktioniert, wäre das schon extrem nice.
Weil bisher hab ich GitHub eigentlich nur verwendet, um Git Repos anzulegen, sonst nix.
Ich mach ja auch die Verwaltung, ich edit hier auch nix über die Oberfläche, ich mach das alles lokal über die Kommandozeile.
Und an sich wäre das aber unglaublich praktisch, weil bisher mach ich so für Hobby-Zeug, auf der Arbeit ist es ein bisschen anders.
Auf der Arbeit haben wir selbst gehaustete Sachen, da haben wir einmal ein Bitbucket und ein paar Jenkins.
Einfach die Dinger bilden und so, aber ist auch egal. Da hab ich daheim überhaupt keinen Bock drauf, weil Jenkins ein bisschen die Pest geworden ist mittlerweile.
Am Anfang war Jenkins ganz cool, so 2015 oder so. Da hab ich auch mal einen eigenen Jenkins für unser Zeug installiert.
Aber mittlerweile ist Jenkins ein bisschen die Pest geworden. Plugins, die von Plugins abhängen mit Dependencies, die davor installiert werden müssen.
Nur das eine Plugin, nur das andere Plugin und in welcher Reihenfolge und sonst was.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr Jenkins verwendet auf der Arbeit oder ob ihr das kennt, das ist quasi so ein Build-Server zum Selbsthosten.
Ah, da legt man dann auch, gucken wir mal da irgendwie, ob es da ein schönes Bild zu gibt.
Ja, da legt man dann so was, macht man da eigentlich eher weniger.
Das Webinterface ist auch, das Webinterface ist auch eklig. Das ist eine Java-Anwendung mit sehr merkwürdigem Webinterface mit 30 Milliarden Optionen.
Jenkins ist cool, kannst alles mitmachen, aber so wahnsinnig schön ist es nicht.
Ich habe ein bisschen mit Drone schon rumgespielt und ein bisschen mit GitLab CI, aber nachdem wir halt auf der Arbeit relativ festgefahren sind, was die internen Tools angeht, bringt mir das da alles nicht viel.
Wir sind gerade ein bisschen dabei, mehr Fokus auf Cloud-Anwendung und generell Cloud-Geschichten zu legen, aber bis da mal unsere internen Sachen alle umgezogen sind,
dass wir vielleicht Azure Pipelines oder Geschichts verwenden können, das ist auf jeden Fall noch eine ganze Weile hin.
So, und deswegen ist das für private Repos sicherlich saumäßig praktisch, wenn man bei jedem Push ins Git-Repo einfach den Build über GitLab laufen lassen kann.
Ich sage manchmal GitLab und mein GitHub, ich sage manchmal GitLab, mein GitLab ist die Benahmung. Das wäre nämlich praktisch, wenn ich hier eine Anwendung pushen könnte und dann hier über GitLab Action das ganze Dependencies installieren,
bilden und auf den Server pushen. Ich habe keinen Schimmer, wie das funktioniert, das probieren wir jetzt aus. Einzige Sache, die ich schon mal gemacht habe, ist hier in dem, also wie gesagt, ich habe da ein Repo angelegt da und eine Sache, die ich schon mal gemacht habe, ist unter Settings einen Key hinkopiert,
mit dem man sich auf meinen Digital Ocean Server einloggen kann, also auf den hier, als dieser User. Also ihr seht, da ist noch nichts drauf. Und wir lassen das Ganze natürlich nicht als Route laufen und das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Wie gesagt, das Repo hier ist komplett leer. Das heißt, wir klonen uns das erst einmal lokal. Komm, wir machen hier Stream. Wir klonen das Ganze mal rein und wir erstellen eine Standard Template ASP.NET Anwendung und sonst nichts.
Also wir programmieren heute nicht großartig herum, wir gucken wirklich, wie wir den Kram automatisch deployed kriegen.
Hast du dir schon mal den Call of Duty Warzone angeguckt? Das habe ich gerade, das ist irgendwie durch, ich weiß nicht. Hast du eigentlich deinen Code für Streaming App, die du mal gemacht hast, mittlerweile auf GitHub veröffentlicht?
Nee, ganz am Anfang mal, du meinst die hier, ne? Also das Ding, wo du auf Overlays einplanen kannst. Ja, ich habe die allererste Version auf GitHub veröffentlicht, aber das neue Ding nirgendwo.
Habe ich auch nicht vor, weil es ist total kaputt. Wisst ihr noch, was es für ein Akt war, das Egal Gift mit dem Sound reinzukriegen?
Das ist 30 Mal abgestürzt dabei, weil ich falsch geklickt habe. Das ist total kaputt, das Ding. Das funktioniert nur bei mir so gut, weil ich weiß, was ich drücken darf und was nicht.
Aldir sagt, ich durfte gestern 20 Notebooks fertig machen. Was gestern 20 Notebooks fertig machen? Corona und so, alle mit USB-Stick installiert. Ah, okay, machen sie bei euch auch Homeoffice-Anläufe.
Was machst du denn jetzt eigentlich gerade? Kirolo, dazu habe ich mal ein Video aufgenommen, ganz ausführlich. Das da. Also wenn du es genau wissen willst, kannst du dieses Video hier angucken, bei mir auf YouTube. Da erkläre ich ganz genau, was ich aktuell auf der Arbeit mache.
Desinfektionsmittel. Hi Leute, ich habe kein Desinfektionsmittel gekauft. Ich habe noch was da. Ich habe auch mittlerweile was bei mir im Rucksack, den ich immer mitnehme. Aber ansonsten, ich gehe eh davon aus, über kurz oder lang kriegen wir den Scheiß alle.
Was ich ja witzig finde, ist, wie sie sich rumdrücken davor irgendwie bei uns. Das ist ja so irgendwie in Italien. Na gut, Italien hat es auch ein bisschen früher, ein bisschen herzer als erst mal getroffen.
Alle anderen so nach dem Motto, ja, hier machen wir zu, hier machen wir zu, hier machen wir zu, hier machen wir zu und bei uns erst mal so, wie könnten wir das jetzt am besten machen? Also es ist wichtig, dass wir entschieden vorgehen.
Das heißt, wir machen jetzt erst mal eine Presseerklärung, in der wir mitteilen, dass wir entschieden vorgehen, als würde das das Virus irgendwie interessieren, ob wir jetzt irgendwie uns zusammengeschlossen sagen und sagen, wir werden entschieden dagegen vorgehen, aber tut sich nichts.
Wie lange die jetzt ewig rummachen? Mr. Bryce, 94 zwei Monate. Was ich auch ein bisschen merkwürdig finde, ist, wenn sie die ganze Zeit so erzählen, so nach dem Motto, ja, wir werden gucken, dass wir ein Wirtschaftspaket auflegen mit nahezu unlimitiert Kohle und sonst was, ist ja alles schön und gut.
Da sag ich gar nichts dagegen, aber vielleicht sollte man nicht nur ein reines Wirtschaftspaket auflegen, sondern auch gucken, dass man die Leute, die eben die Kohle brauchen, irgendwie unterstützen kann, weil überlegt euch mal, überlegt euch mal, ihr seid jetzt irgendwie Eltern von fünf Kindern oder so, irgendwie zwei gehen den Kindergarten, drei gehen in die Schule und die Eltern, was sollen die machen?
Die Eltern müssen entweder daheim bleiben oder aber sie können es sich nicht leisten und da geht dann quasi einer Not getrunken arbeiten, auch in irgendwelchen Zeiten, wo die halbe Stadt schon infiziert ist, weil er Kohle braucht.
Also es ist, ich hab das Gefühl, wir tun uns da unglaublich schwer, damit mal irgendwas zu entscheiden. Also wir brauchen wahrscheinlich erstmal zwei, wusstet ihr, dass bis Freitag, habe ich gelesen, bis Freitag hat das Robert-Koch-Institut die infizierten Zahlen, die infizierten Zahlen, haltet euch fest, per Brief gemeldet, per Brief.
Also wir sind da in Deutschland nicht so aktuell, was so Dinge anbelangt. Man konnte nicht einfach irgendwie eine E-Mail hinschreiben oder irgendwie einen Discord aufmachen oder irgendwie, oh Gott, Discord, ich will gar nicht, woüber man drauf kommt, oder irgendwie einfach nur anrufen, nein, per Brief.
Das heißt, die Zahlen aus Deutschland sind ca. drei Jahre veraltet, richtig, richtig, deswegen gab es auch so einen großen Sprung am Freitag. Am Freitag gab es einen Sprung von, ich glaub, 250 auf 850 und in Wirklichkeit war es nicht ganz so schlimm, sondern sie haben am Freitag umgestellt, dass das Ganze elektronisch gemeldet wird.
Es ist, es ist, es ist echt sehr merkwürdig. Keine Brieftaube, ja.
So, jetzt haben wir unser Git repo geklont. Mit Stream-App meinte ich, wo du mit FFmpeg und ASP.NET Core Video gestreamt hast.
Was? Meinst du mein, mein Webcam? Meinst, meinst du das Webcam? Programm oder was?
Nee, das hab ich, das ist auch noch gar nicht fertig, ich hab dann irgendwann keinen Bock mehr gehabt. Ich kenn mich ja, ich fange immer Sachen an und hab dann irgendwie keinen Bock mehr und hör auf.
So, also hier ist unser repo, da ist jetzt, da ist jetzt nichts drinne. Wir machen jetzt eine stinknormale Leere, stinknormale Leere, ASP.NET Core Anwendung, die nichts anderes kann, wie Hallo Welt ausgeben.
Und dann gucken wir, wie wir den ganzen Kram der Heizer Exporter, dann kriegen wir, da gucken wir, wie wir den ganzen Kram, hier, Hello, nee, was war das, what?
Hello World App, Big Brain Name. Und das erstellen wir nicht hier, sondern in Stream.
So, und die kann nix außer Hallo Welt ausgeben. Das reicht auch, oder können wir nämlich gucken, ob wir das ganze deployen können mit GitHub Actions.
Oh, ich bin doof, ich hab's im falschen Ding erstellt, naja, was auch immer. Wir müssen auch gar nichts machen, ich glaube, was die standardmäßig machen ist hier irgendwie aufs Hello World ausgeben, auf starten.
What? Was ist denn das? Was not found? Das ist, das ist irgendeine Art Repo-Geschichte, die kaputt ist, glaube ich.
So, wir kopieren den ganzen Kram gerade mal hier in das... Ach ja, genau, ich muss noch hier den Kram irgendwie installieren, das ist irgendwie ziemlich kaputt. Den Kram muss man installieren, dass es läuft.
Ist das jetzt den in Ernst? Muss ich jetzt auch noch ein System-Update machen, das ich anfangen darf? Ach du... Ich hab schon eine Weile nicht mehr geupdatet, wie es aussieht.
Also Leute, wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt, sagt Bescheid. Wir müssen jetzt mal kurz zwei Minuten Betriebssystem-Update machen.
Jetzt senden die bestimmt über ICQ. Die haben bestimmt einen internen Messenger, weil wir verwenden ja, wir programmieren ja die Sachen lieber selbst.
Das ist genauso wie diese offizielle Zeiterfassungs-App, die es von irgendeinem Amt gab, die sie dann wieder eingestellt haben.
Caspar sagt, Alter, muss jetzt meine ganze Schulung über Microsoft Teams machen, die Scheiße ist so verbugged. Also zu Microsoft Teams kann ich dir nur Folgendes sagen.
Ich hab am Freitag mal ausprobiert, ob man GIFs darüber verschicken kann. Und da ist mir aufgefallen, wenn man GIFs reincopy-pastet, geht das Ganze nicht. Wenn man GIFs über diese Attach-Nadel anhängt, dann gehen die GIFs auch als Animation.
Das ist wichtig, wenn du Teams verwendest, das muss man wissen. Wozu soll man Teams verwenden, wenn man keine GIFs posten kann.
Aber was richtig cool ist, Teams hat, wenn man da draufklickt, dann hat das einen eigenen Memes-Generator. Aber da sind nur die harmlosen Bildchen drin.
Der Sebaro ist am Start. Der Cute-Mod-Hooks persönlich. Nutzt du eigentlich die Alias-Funktion von Git? Ja, ja. Ich hab aber hier keine drauf.
Ich muss mir die mal von der Arbeit sunken. Ich hab Git-ST für Status, Git-CO für Check-Out. Das sind die am häufigsten verwendetsten.
Die hab ich hier aber gerade nicht drauf auf der Streaming-VM. Guck mal, das Update ist schon durch. Pog.
Ich hab's ja gestern auf Twitter gepostet. Das hat mich mal wieder voll bestätigt.
Ich hab ein Video gefunden auf einer GIF-Seite, die lustigerweise auch Sound kann. Die meisten GIF-Seiten haben ja nur GIF im Namen.
Das sind ganz normale Video-Seiten plus GIF von irgendwelchen Leuten in Italien, die im Corona-Sperrgebiet rumgestanden haben am Fenster und auf der Straße und haben zum Zusammenhalt die italienische Nationalhymne angestimmt und gesungen.
Und ich hab mich so gefragt, wie würde das in Deutschland ankommen? Wir sind ja generell sehr empfindlich, was sowas angeht. Ich hab mir gestern so überlegt, wenn es hier quasi ein Video geben würde, wo die Leute am Fenster stehen und die Nationalhymne singen, da wäre wahrscheinlich schon wieder der Shitstorm ausgebrochen.
Ob das jetzt nicht Hate Speech oder sowas ist. Und da hab ich auf Twitter gestern sowas in der Richtung gepostet und lustigerweise ging direkt danach die Diskussion los, dass es ja komplett unnötiger Nationalismus ist, wenn die Italiener zum Zusammenhalt die Nationalhymne singen.
Und da hab ich mir gesagt, alter Leute, über was für eine Scheiße man sich alles Gedanken machen kann, der hätt ich im Leben nicht dran gedacht, dass man sich da auch nur ansatzweise dran stören kann.
Aber wenn wir schon darüber diskutieren, wenn Italiener die italienische Nationalhymne am Fenster singen, was ist dann erst los, wenn wir mal wirklich ein halbes Dorf, wenn hier die deutschen Nationalhymne singen würden.
Aber wir machen die Sachen ja gerne bürokratisch. Ich geh mal davon aus, bei uns wird erstmal ein offizielles Gutachten eingeholt, wie viele unterschiedliche Nationalitäten in diesem Dorf leben und dann werden mal mindestens 14 verschiedene Nationalhymnen gesungen.
Weil das muss ja alles seine Ordnung haben. Oder aber wir singen Helene Fischer, das könnte auch sein. Weil wahrscheinlich können mehr Leute Helene Fischer, ich mein Atemlos passt ja auch zu Corona irgendwie ganz gut.
Weil ich glaube, es können mehr Helene Fischer singen als die deutschen Nationalhymne. Ich kann die deutschen Nationalhymne auch nur die aktuell erste Strophe irgendwie zur Hälfte. Vergiss es, ich krieg das überhaupt nicht gebacken.
Ich komm auch nicht weit, ich komm auch nicht weiter. So, also dann pushen wir den Kram mal.
Achso, wir müssen erstmal gucken, ob die App funktioniert..net run. What?
Alter, wo ist das Problem? Was spackt der denn hier wieder rum? Achso, ich bin im falschen Verzeichnis, keck. Was? Was spackt denn der rum?
Alter, das nervt man nicht. Ich will einfach eine Hello World App anlegen. Meine Güte, wo ist das Problem? Ah, neu.
Der Moment, wenn ich mal Hello World funktioniere, ich weiß auch nicht, was da gerade los ist. Ich dachte, ich erstell den Kram und dann ist es gut. Soll ich mal restarten?
Das ist eigentlich Schwachsinn, ich muss nicht restarten. Ich hab geupdatet, guck mal mal. Windows Zeug, ja.
Ist das Witcher Musik, oder? Nee. Kein Init 6.
Was? Ich hab jetzt rebooted, oder? Ich hab schon volle Brain-Aussetzer. Hab ich jetzt rebooted? Ich hab rebooted, oder? Weil es sieht alles genauso aus wie vorher.
Ja, ich hab rebooted, gut. Was kann, was kann, was kann die hier standardmäßig?.net-new-web kann man doch machen, oder?
.net-new-web. So, letztmal mal.net-run. Warum zum Geier geht noch nicht mal mein Publisches Hello World? Was ist denn, was hab ich denn hier paketmäßig kaputt gemacht?
Was? Was ist da kaputt? Achso, ich muss das Paket ja noch installieren. Aber es ging ja vorher nicht. Jetzt funktioniert es auch.
So schön, also, sehr schön. Was die App kann, ist huge, einfach Hello World ausgeben. Das reicht aber zum Testen schon voll und ganz aus. Geht Status.
Hallo. Egal, wir committen einfach alles. Wir committen einfach alles. Bäm, alles wird committet. So, blub, beste Commit-Message. Push.
Gut, so. Wenn wir jetzt in unser GitHub-Repo gehen, also da, dann sehen wir auch, da ist die App drinne. So, und was wir jetzt ausprobieren ist, ob wir diese Map, äh die Map, was erzähl ich?
Die App, ob wir die so automatisch bilden können, dass wir die auf meinen Digital Ocean Server schieben können unter diesem User und sie starten können und dann per Browser drauf zugreifen.
Also sprich, das Ziel ist, dass ich hier drauf gehe auf die IP danach und Hello World rauskriege. Was so natürlich nicht funktioniert.
So, und das coole ist daran, wenn das funktioniert, dann kann ich jetzt was ändern. Ich committe das, ich pushe das, der bildet das, schiebt es automatisch auf meinen Server, stoppt die aktuelle Anwendung,
push die, äh kopiert die neue Anwendung rüber und startet sie. Also wenn das so funktioniert, wie ich mir das denke, was natürlich sehr praktisch ist, weil dann muss ich einfach nur, ähm, sagen wir mal, mein Pranscher Master Merchant oder irgendwie einen Tag drauf machen oder wie auch immer es funktioniert, muss ich gleich mal gucken.
Und dann läuft es dann irgendwie ein paar Sekunden später auf meinem Server drauf, wenn das so funktioniert, wie ich mir das Ganze vorgestellt habe. Also gucken wir jetzt erstmal, wie das Ganze klappt.
Erstmal gucken, wie das geht. Ich weiß, dass man auf Actions klicken muss und ich habe auch schon mal in einem anderen Repo vor einer Weile was angelegt.
Also es ist nicht so, dass ich es komplett... Guck mal hier, build and test your C-Sharp Repository. Der bildet mir sogar, der bietet mir sogar an, äh, einen Test, einen.NET Test Workflow zu machen.
Probieren wir mal aus. Setup this Workflow.
What?
Ok, es läuft schon mal auf Ubuntu.
Warum auch nicht? Es gibt da sonst noch Sozialauswahl. Das hat wohl Autocomplete hier das Ganze?
So 1804 bietet es sich an, weil auf meinem Server ist glaube auch 1804.
Ja, dann passt das ja ganz gut.
So, was macht der hier denn jetzt?
So, das ist irgendein Name, den man vergeben kann, wie man will.
Der triggert neue Builds, wenn auf Master gepusht wird, das ist gut.
So, das Ganze läuft unter Ubuntu 1804 als Test.
So, und was macht der da jetzt?
Actions, Checkout. Ok, der klont sich das Repo wahrscheinlich.
Und der legt...
Der installiert.NET in Ubuntu 1804. Und dann pretiere ich da jetzt mal so rein. Und dann macht er ein Build.
Gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Zumindest sollte er das jetzt automatisch machen. Ich meine, er pusht das nicht auf den Server, da muss ich erstmal gucken, wie der Kram funktioniert.
Sollte der jetzt nicht starten? Ah, guck mal, der startet. Easy.
Wie, das was jetzt?
Wirklich was gemacht hat er jetzt nicht, oder?
Der hat den nächsten Step doch gar nicht ausgeführt.
Was ist denn das für ein Crap? Ach doch, der hat es einfach nicht angezeigt.
Der hat es einfach nicht angezeigt, weil es verbackt ist irgendwie.
So, also der hat.NET Core installiert. Der hat die Anwendung gebildet.
Ja, das war's. Mehr soll er ja auch an der Stelle nicht machen.
Bekommt man dann Artifacts wieder oder was? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
So, also wie kann man den Kram jetzt erweitern? Also die Anwendung bauen funktioniert schon mal.
Das ist natürlich schon mal praktisch, dass das so direkt funktioniert. Aber jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie kriege ich den Kram bei mir auf den Server drauf?
Also ich sehe da, ich sehe da zwei Varianten. Entweder, dass wir uns quasi irgendwie einen ZIP oder sowas generieren lassen, was wir dann auf den Server pullen.
Oder, was ich viel cooler finden würde, wenn GitHub das auf den Server irgendwie rüber rücken könnte oder SCPen oder SSHen oder was auch immer.
Und ich muss sagen, sie haben hier auch einen ganz halbwegs ordentlichen Editor. Also was haben wir hier? Upload, Upload, Artifact.
Probieren wir das mal aus. Und jetzt? Wo, wo mache ich das hin? Hier unten drunter? Oh, ne.
So. Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich da wirklich mache. Test? Directory containing files to upload.
Was weiß ich, wo meine Files sind? Sieht man das hier irgendwo im Output?
Ah, hier, guck mal. Actions repo bin release? Moment. Das ist ja plötzend, was ich hier mache. Das will ich doch gar nicht.
Warte mal, ich kommentiere den Kram aus. Das will ich doch so gar nicht, was der da bildet. Das ist doch komplett...
Ich will kein.NET Bild machen. Ich will ein.NET Publish. Ich will ja, dass der eine Anwendung baut, die alleine läuft, ohne installiertes.NET.
Wie viele Bildminuten hat man da? Ich glaube unlimited. Dafür muss man halt warten, wenn viel los ist.
Also was ich eigentlich machen will, ist.NET Publish, Publish. Da macht er doch. Publish minus c release minus minus self contain.
ich glaube das hat so funktioniert
ne
äh äh äh
äh wie ist denn die richtige
achso genau ich muss noch linux
angeben linux
ähm linux
x64
so und was er jetzt
macht ist jetzt erstellt er mir ne version
von meiner anwendung hier in dem ordner
die komplett
auffähig ist
ohne
ohne installiertes also die ist quasi
so halb kompiliert
sie ist nicht wirklich komplett binary
es ist quasi ne dotnet runtime mit
ähm
embedded zeugs drinne
so das ist nämlich das schöne weil ich möchte
auf meinem server weder dotnet
noch sonst was installieren müssen ich will ja dass die
anwendung komplett bei github gebaut
wird und dann auf meinen server gepusht wird
also was will ich machen dotnet publish
das will ich ja eigentlich machen
so gucken wir mal was github jetzt
macht
kommt mit
kann man ihm zugucken wie er bildet
so dass er
live live den kram aktualisiert
also ich glaube man hat
wie gesagt ich glaube man hat unlimited
oh
ok
oder auch nicht
ähm
wo steht denn da wieviel man was hat
ja
2000 minuten
äh wieviel
hat man bei github
oder was
ja 2000
ja nimmt sich nichts
dann hat man eigentlich nur den vorteil
dass github an sich verbreitet
aber für private
gepos ist das eigentlich vollkommen egal
vollkommen egal
man kann guck mal man kann man kann seine eigene github cdings irgendwie
hausten warum auch immer ich das machen will
der sinn ist ja gerade dass das nicht bei mir laufen muss
also was die machen können das habe ich auf dem vortrag gesehen
was cool ist
weil es der tanzer gerade schreibt was cool ist man kann builds machen
unter linux unter windows und unter mac
und irgendwie mit einem eigenen dockercontainer oder irgendwie sowas
und das ist sehr praktisch
das ist sehr praktisch weil
es gibt viele leute die wollen ihre ios apps wahrscheinlich bilden oder
irgendwelche irgendwelche mac
geschichten bilden
das geht halt nicht unter linux gescheit
du brauchst ja zwingend
du brauchst ja zwingend in mac dass du app store apps machen kannst
also gucken wir jetzt mal was hier rausgekommen ist wo das ganze liegt da
home runner work
action repos bin
ein
exzellenter
eingängiger
fahrt ist das ganze jahr
home runner work action test repo action test repo bin released
netcore 3.1 linux x64 publish
genauso hätte ich es gemacht
so und jetzt kriegen wir jetzt müsste der uns einen zip anhängen oder sowas
upload artifact name path
muss man da einfach so machen
oder kann ich da auch
oder kann ich da auch sowas hier angeben
kann es wahrscheinlich relativ zu meinem home angeben also zu dem repo was
ausgecheckt ist
probieren wir jetzt mal aus ob das funktioniert
ich denke auch dass es als zip dann irgendwo erscheinen müsste ja
denke ich auch
schauen wir mal
ja er checkt das repo aus
es ruckelt ein bisschen
aber ich will mich jetzt mal nicht beschweren dass
dass die
github actions nicht mit 60 fps laufen
so er bildet eine self contained anwendung
was wichtig ist weil ich auf meinem server kein toilet installieren will
oh oh oh je
pass does not exist oh jetzt macht er das doppelt
das heißt ich habe es einmal zu viel geschrieben
auch gut
das heißt wir editieren den ganzen kram noch mal
und wir bleiben hier mal da und machen den anderen kram zu
wir editieren den kram noch mal und machen das da raus
und dann sollte es funktionieren
dann sollten wir ihnen einen zip von der anwendung kriegen und dann ist die frage was ich mit diesem zip mache
ich habe gerade destroy stats deploy gelesen
das kommt manchmal aufs gleiche raus
also wenn ich mir überlege
an mir auf der arbeit
wie oft ein deployment komplett funktioniert hat ohne dass danach
irgendwas nicht ginge kann ich das an einer hand abzählen
selbstverständlich nicht für die anwendung wo ich zuständig bin
da kann sowas ja natürlich nicht passieren
selbstreden
so upload
oh guck mal er uploadet
wo uploadet er denn hin
er uploadet
ach guck mal hier
da ist das
da ist mal ein zip
das ist die fertig gebaute anwendung jetzt drin
das probieren wir aus wir laden mal das das das das zip das zip runter
ich meine das ist jetzt nur die halbe miete das müssen wir auf dem server dann machen
ähm
jetzt so
guck mal rein
ja da ist der ganze kram
oh das ist was ohne ordner
auspacken
da ist die anwendung drinne komplett fertig gebaut
aber
die ist nicht ausführbar ne
also muss ich sagen chmod plus x das muss ich dann wahrscheinlich auf dem server auch noch machen
ach quatsch das ding heißt ja ah hier action heißt ja gar nicht mehr web application
funktioniert
also sprich
upload
github baut für mich
und macht ein zip draus das ist doch schon mal ganz praktisch
jetzt natürlich plus die preisfrage
wie ich den ganzen kram auf meinen server krieg
also was haben wir denn hier sonst noch für
ssh actions oder sowas ssh commands das klingt doch schon mal gut
ssh commands ssh deploy
klingt auch schon mal nicht schlecht
copy via ssh
ich meine das mit 250 sterne scheint doch
ganz praktisch zu sein
gucken wir uns mal das an und gucken wir uns mal das an
ich meine ich brauche ja zwei sachen was cool wäre wenn es ein plugin gäbe was SCPen kann
und was danach befehle ausführen kann
also von der idee her müssten wir ja folgendes machen
ich müsste auf den server mich verbinden
dort quasi die anwendung hinkopieren
und dann müsste ich die anwendung ja noch starten mit einem befehl auf dem server
so muss ich halt überhaupt nichts auf dem server einrichten
und was dann hat überlegt euch mal was richtig cool ist mal angenommen
man hat hier jetzt man hat eine anwendung für irgendwie drei verschiedene
kunden oder so
und
was weiß ich was weiß ich was irgendwie eine neue version
und man hat quasi für jeden kunde irgendwie eine branche mit ein paar custom sachen
drinnen
sei es nur config files dann könnte man quasi so einstellen
dass es wenn ich branche a pushe
dass den job für branche a anwirft und auf den richtigen server beziehungsweise
in das richtige verzeichnis
für die richtige subdomain die pleuten den kram neu startet
pro tech
das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool
ich meine das kann man mit einem eigenen ci selber natürlich auch ohne probleme machen aber
das schöne ist ja bei so cloud geschichten
man hat es von der backe
oder nee man hat es nicht an der backe so rum oder von der backe
der sebaro sagt was bringt mir eigentlich dieses serverless zum beispiel in bezug
auf
ja was geht heißen go oh gott serverless
serverless fangt
also
erstens ist serverless
so ein bisschen sowas wie
wie cloud und big data und und
agile enterprise multispeed architekturen also ein bisschen buzzword
geschwitze
was damit mit serverless ist ja gar nicht serverless gemeint
der witz an serverless ist eigentlich dass der server nur nicht bei dir steht
also es ist ein bisschen es ist ein bisschen wie bei der cloud
am ende am ende
wenn du eine anwendung hast die irgendwie super microservice serverless
in der cloud sonst wie läuft
am ende
steht da immer noch
ein webserver der deine webseite ausliefert oder sowas immer
wie soll denn weil wie soll sonst
der jeweilige client den kram auch sich anzeigen lassen können
macht keinen Unterschied also
dass man serverless serverless nennt ist eigentlich
komplett beknackt in anbetracht der tatsache dass man zu natürlich server
braucht ja
der einzige unterschied ist dass die server nicht bei dir stehen
und
das geht halt ein bisschen hand in hand mit dem aktuellen trend
dass man viele sache auslagert
und dann auch wie man es wie man so schön nennt mittlerweile function as a
service und microservice also sprich
dass du
nicht mehr
große zusammenhängende anwendungen bastelst
quasi anwendungen die aus mehreren kleinen teilen bestehen
die nach möglichkeit dann auch nicht von dir
programmiert werden müssen und nicht von dir betreut werden müssen
ja das trifft
just player
serverless verteiltes system was nicht bei dir steht
was natürlich nicht heißt dass nicht trotzdem teilweise von einem selbst noch
daten gebraucht werden oder man doch irgendwas brauche
es ist einfach unglaublich schwammig was sagt was sagt denn wikipedia dazu
eigentlich
das nicht wikipedia ich will
braucht was ich will ist wikipedia
ist cloud computing execution mode
genau
cloud provider runs the server also wie ich gesagt habe von wegen
von wegen serverless
das ist das ist im prinzip nur ein buzzword
das ist die die extended variante von cloud
ist jetzt serverless
hat man ja so ein bisschen ein bisschen tot geritten
als buzzword
und jetzt hat man halt zusätzlich noch
noch serverless
du kannst ja auch
weil einer gerade kubernetes eingeschmissen hat
man kann ja auch dann quasi
den den den azure kubernetes server verwenden
wie wie hast du aks
azure kubernetes service kannst du auch verwenden
du kannst im prinzip mittlerweile
fast alles machen ohne dass du selbst noch großartig infrastruktur brauchst
wenn man das will wohlgemerkt ich meine das hat auch seine daseinsberechtigung
wenn man manche sachen da wenn man manche sachen selbst machen will
erstens kann das im kleinen stil tatsächlich eine ganze ecke günstiger
sein
also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie so ein zwei drei mann software team bin
die irgendwie eine sache betreiben für irgendwie 40 40 leute die das system
verwenden
muss das nicht unbedingt
so also mit selbst betreiben meine ich jetzt nicht
dass man den server bei sich bestehen hat stehen hat quasi im keller oder so
sondern dass man irgendwo halt einen server gemietet hat und den selbst
betreiben also richtig richtig hart wenn bei sich hinstellen
da brauchst du schon wirklich gute gründe wenn man das machen will
zum beispiel ein ein ein guter kund ist wenn man da kundendaten drauf hat oder
vielleicht irgendwelche sensiblen sachen
die man entweder gesetzlich nicht weggeben darf
oder die man halt aufgrund von
schittstorm risiko nicht weggeben will
michael 50 billionen ist auch am start
ich habe gar kein winkel im ort fällt mir gerade ein
aber was ich da immer noch dazu hinzufügen muss das hat es hat wie immer
alles seine vornacht teile
das heißt man muss gucken
was ich für das jeweilige gebiet was man jetzt wo man halt gerade was
betreiben möchte oder gerade was programmieren will oder
ja machen möchte was ich da lohnt
es ist komplett
komplett beknackt
wie das beispielsweise hier auf auf reddit
eine form was ich immer ganz gerne lesen jetzt abrätig selbst forstet
eine sache wo ich halt hier überhaupt nicht mit einverstanden bin ist
dass die
absoluten nupe heim am wehrheim anwender
die quasi gerade mal zwei raspberry pies erfolgreich daheim installiert haben
erzählen wollen
wenn ihr daheim selbst anwendung hosten wollt installiert euch erst mal ein
kubernetes cluster
kompletter schwachsinn
für fünf für fünf anwendungen daheim
das ist total hängen geblieben wozu das verwirrt die leute nur und nur
unnötig
und es ist ja nicht so als wäre das
nicht von der komplexität her dann auf einmal
quasi dann ist dann ist das verwalten das verwalten der infrastruktur
komplexer als die anwendung die darauf sind
was ist denn x-pen ology das ist der
oder nicht nicht der umso aus dieser dieser sein ology dass die da die das
betriebssystem von
von sein ology irgendwie abgezogen haben
und das zum selbst installieren veröffentlichen
das da
als jahre quasi das sein ology betriebssystem genommen und
dass man sich selbst installieren kann
oh leute
das ist wohl
monka tos
warum habe ich kein monka tos doch habe ich
gibt's die seite noch
mal gespannt wo die jetzt gehostet sind
also auf github gibt's die ganze gibt sie nicht mehr
also artheas ich habe jetzt schon ziemlich oft gesehen dass die leute
das ist zumindest neuling in den kopf setzen wollen dass er mit kuppernähtes
alles super easy ist und man eigentlich kein richtiger
es selbst holster ist mehr ohne kuppernähtes was eigentlich was war
schwachsinnig ist ja
ich bin froh wenn das ein bisschen abgenommen hat bin ich der letzte was
dagegen hat
dass man docker verwenden sollte
ist auch
nicht unbedingt pauschal richtig also sprich wenn ich jetzt einfach nur
wenn falls aber installieren will also sprich installieren in den ubuntu-server macht
den sambar drauf und fertig mit der usb festplatte dran
dann brauche ich auch kein docker
es ist wie immer man muss gucken was man machen will
und dann schauen was passt
okay machen wir weiter also wo sind wir hier stehen geblieben
wir wollten gucken wie man das ganze über ssh kopieren kann also was haben wir
zur auswahl hier
ssh commands
die musik ist ein bisschen zu
episch für meinen geschmack
äh linux kommando zeile
ubuntu ja
kann man hier einen key ah key key content
key pass
also macht man secrets ok
also führt man auf dem ok so führt man auf dem server sachen aus
und wie kopiere ich jetzt sachen rüber auf mein server
wir probieren das mal wir probieren erst mal ob ich einfach stink normale
kommandos ausführen kann auf einem system das reicht ja schon mal
da kann ich gucken ob das klappt so
execute remote ssh command using ssh key
so secrets
ähm
ich hab mein secret hab ich glaube ich wie hab ich denn genannt server key
server
server key
host ist
wir tragen jetzt mal die statische ip von dem ding ein
host ist das
usernamen ist stream
läuft da linux in hyper-v
du meinst bei denen hier ne glaub ich nicht
das ist wahrscheinlich alles docker container hier unter der haube alles
alles linux mäßige wird ja wahrscheinlich eh welches docker container sein
gehe ich mal von aus mit hyper-v wäre das
da kannst du viel zu wenig laufen lassen
aber mir nö
das ist vor allem ein workstation
secret server port 22
script
who am i ok
wie kann man denn mehrere
sachen ausführen
ssh actions
ah hier
script
script who am i ls-la
wunderbar
schauen wir mal ob das einloggen funktioniert
ob das einloggen auf dem server funktioniert
hast noch keine keys festgelegt doch hab ich
hab ich hier guck
das sind die secrets die ich hinterlegt hab in den project settings
hoffe ich mal dass das so geht aber müsste weil im beispiel steht so drinnen
schauen wir mal
oh upload artefact ok das kann ich wieder rausnehmen das brauche ich nicht
wobei vielleicht brauche ich vielleicht kann ich das ja dann rüber kopieren
das ist zip
aber das mache ich mal raus das das braucht nur unnötig braucht nur unnötig speicherplatz
auf github
auf der anderen seite warum soll es mich jucken ist ja nicht mein speicherplatz
hat das jetzt funktioniert
ich glaube das backt rum
das geht
das funktioniert
guck mal da hat sich auf meinen server verbunden
und hat
ausgegeben ich bin user stream und die datei in meinem heimatverzeichnis
das ist das ok das ist ziemlich das war jetzt ziemlich
ziemlich einfach ehrlich gesagt
so da war jetzt mal hier das das da wieder wobei war warum editiert das
überhaupt im browser ich kann das doch bestimmt viel schöner ich kann es doch
bestimmt viel schöner hier editieren
kann es doch bestimmt viel schöner hier editieren
ja stimmt im browser habe ich autovervollständigung ja das ist richtig
soll ich soll ich euch mal den richtig übertriebenen
vim hack zeigen
ihr müsst groß i drücken
groß i drücken
oh schwachsinn hat nicht funktioniert ihr müsst markieren markieren
kommentarzeichen machen es kämpftrücken und dann sollte er
oder auch nicht das habe ich jetzt falsch gemacht
ach nee ich muss ich muss blockselekt machen ne noch blockselekt groß i kommentar und jetzt
escape
ah jetzt hat funktioniert excellent
excellent vim magic
weißte was
ich mach den ganzen kram hier mal raus bild mit dotnet will ich nämlich behalten
ich will bloß das artifact upload rausschmeißen
also wenn es das ha funktioniert wie kriege ich meine anwendung auf den server jetzt übertragen
erstmal gucken ob es klappt wenn ich das über die kommen wir übers git quasi von der
comando zeile aus update wir machen jetzt eine runde noch mal git git magic und zwar
wenn wir jetzt in unser log gucken
mit einem wahnsinnig tollen
username den wir hier haben
was man jetzt machen kann wenn man dann git report wohlgemerkt ich sage euch gleich das
macht man nicht in öffentlichen branches das macht man nur in eigenen
aber ich meine ich außer mir verwende das ganze gesamte repo kein so ihr kennt das wahrscheinlich
wenn ihr eine weile gebastelt habt ihr jede menge solcher sinnlosen
sinnlosen comments ja im prinzip im prinzip würde würde eigentlich das kommet hier reichen
mit den aktuellen änderungen
dort habt ihr mehrere möglichkeiten
ja siehst du ich sehe schon der chat der chat kennt sich aus
rebasen kannst du kannst quatschen
einfachste finde ich ist
man macht ein git reset auf das kommet wo man anfängt
wohlgemerkt einfach nur ein reset
also das hier sollte man nicht machen einfach ein stück normalen reset
wenn man jetzt guckt wird man sehen ok
ich habe hier quasi im verzeichnis selber ist noch alles da
auch die ganzen änderungen
aber in der history ist bloß das da drinnen
übrigens das das lösche ich bei der gelegen also in der history ist nur das das aktuelle
kommet drin
ich lösche mal kurz hier mein lokales bild
weil das will ich ja alles brauche alles gar nicht
so wenn ich das jetzt gemacht habe
da ich einfach all anhängen
und schon habe ich alles quasi in diesem kommet drinne was man jetzt hier allerdings
auch schon sieht ist dass die history nicht mal stimmt also sprich nachdem ich jetzt ja
kommets aus der history gelöscht habe
ich habe hier viel mehr kommets auf dem remote wie lokal
deswegen geht das ganze jetzt nicht
erste mal wenn ich das ganze jetzt versuche zu pushen
zu pushen dann mag er nicht
weil er sagt deine history sieht komplett anders aus als meine history
deswegen ist das der einzige grund der mir so einfällt wo man force pusht
so und wie gesagt normalerweise macht man das auf dem master nicht
das macht man nur in branches die man alleine verwendet
weil wenn man das auf dem master branch macht
ein vorausgesetzter master branch ist das wo die anderen leute auch als basis für ihre
entwicklung features was auch immer verwenden
dann hat man richtig große probleme wenn der kram gemercht werden soll später
das heißt master wird nie resettet wird nie rebased
sofern andere leute den kram verwenden
macht man nicht außer man möchte dass 15 leute bei einem am tisch stehen und rum nerven
das macht man nur in eigenen branches oder aber in einem repo was man alleine verwendet
so und jetzt gucken wir mal ob der ob der bild der bild
ach ne ich hab noch gar nicht doch ich hab gepusht ob der bild durch ist was er gemacht hat
vor 44 sekunden ok
bild dann funktioniert und hat gebildet
github ohne dark theme ja stimmt das müssen wir unbedingt anmachen
warum hatten der warum hatten der das ssh nicht executed
warum hatten der das ssh jetzt nicht gemacht
github actions sowas wie continuous yes sowas sowas ja aber wie gesagt ich hab es ja auch
noch nicht verwendet was hat er denn jetzt für schmerzen
vor allem wie ich hier meinen ganzen kram eingecheckt habe
was hat er denn jetzt für schmerzen warum hat er denn jetzt
was der unterschied zwischen rebase und reset in dem context in dem du es gerade verwendest
das führt auch beides zum gleichen ziel
unter der haube ist es was was anderes also ein reset ist halt genau das was man gesehen
hat da geht in der history zurück auf das comet was angegeben hast und macht dann ein
neues comet
so was bei einem rebase funktioniert ist bei einem normalen rebase ist der resettet hart
auf einen speziellen stand und cherry pick dann quasi obendrauf nachdem er resettet hat
alle alle comets die noch da waren was dazu führt dass wenn du rebase machst die comets
noch da sind aber halt dein
dein branch unten drunter so aussieht als hättest du ihn quasi gerade checkout gemacht
du kannst man kann die dinger squashen und sonst was ja dann wird es unter der haube
wahrscheinlich aufs gleiche rauskommen wie wenn du ein reset machst aber ich mach das
lieber mit einem reset
die hape 911 hat es subscribt für sechs monate huge
ich bin ja auch doof ich hätte den kram mal enden müssen vorher
jetzt ist alles dran ja das ssh zeug ist weg weil ich ich hab resettert auf einen stand
wo das noch nicht im repo anscheinend drin war und dann mag er das nicht da muss man
das noch mal noch mal neu enden so aber jetzt ist drin
so schauen wir mal so und dann ist die nächste frage wie kriege ich den kram auf meinen
server kopiert
irgendwie habe ich bei den github actions angst vor vendor login ja das kann ja durchaus
passieren aber auf der anderen seite ich meine das ist unter der haube sind es ja irgendwie
keine 20 zeilen shell script so was das da macht da kann man
also zumindest für so was einfach ist wenn man natürlich als komplexe sachen bastelt
ja also wenn man so ultra komplexe sachen hat wahrscheinlich würde ich mir dann irgendwie
was eigenes basteln
was auch den vorteil hat dass ich meinen private key nicht auf github legen muss
aktuell funktioniert der ganze kram ja nur weil ich in im secret file also hier in github
secrets mein private key drinne habe um auf den server als der user zu kommen
also wenn ich wirklich wichtige systeme hätte und das machen wir wahrscheinlich würde
ich was eigenes basteln
ich meine irgendwie muss man sich auf dem server einloggen also
wobei ich nicht so ganz ganz glücklich mit der lösung hier quasi den den den private
key reinschreiben zu müssen bin ich nicht
okay
hallo ich möchte gerne ausklappen ausklappen github
okay das hat funktioniert so wie kriege ich das jetzt hin
kannst du nicht ssh oder scp
nee weil ich ja kein ssh oder scp ausführe sondern diese komische action für mich das
macht
so und das führt er halt auf dem server aus was ich jetzt machen könnte ist quasi hier
den weget von github aber mein repo ist private und das soll es auch bleiben
dann eine scp action ja wahrscheinlich brauche ich eine scp action
ist ein bisschen doof dass das nicht all das ist nicht in einem ist
ja das könnte ich machen das habe ich auch gerade überlegt aber am liebsten würde
ich überhaupt nichts auf einem server machen
okay also was haben wir die ssh deploy deploy code with rsync
ssh commands was haben wir da sonst noch schönes
guck mal github actions ist da noch scp scp files okay wir gucken mal wir gucken mal was
neuer ist das da ist 17 tage 17 tage ago
und das hier ist ein bisschen länger
okay was jetzt besser ist wahrscheinlich macht es überhaupt keinen unterschied
ach das ist unter der haube rsync okay
werden diese actions auch ausgeführt wenn man ein repo mit so einer action file folgt
ja das kann man einstellen das habe ich das ich weiß aber nicht wo das habe ich in dem
in dem talk gesehen man kann irgendwo einstellen
wann das ganze getriggert wird also sprich ich kann auch sagen wenn einer ein pull request
macht dann lasst was laufen aber die actions werden auf jeden fall nicht
mit geforkt das wäre ja fatal wenn ich da passwörter
drin stehen hätte und er folgt meine actions mit wir nehmen jetzt mal das das ist von dem
gleichen plugin plugin hersteller wie bei dem anderen
das editieren wir jetzt mal hier da habe ich dass ich autocomplete auf github habe
am besten noch die secrets mitforken
so also das müssen wir ja davor kopieren
da kann man doch bestimmt leer zeigen das ist doch erlaubt das ist doch jammel da darf
man doch new lines rein machen das ist doch erlaubt
so dass man ein bisschen so dass man ein bisschen besser durchblickt
ok also copy files via ssh copy files scp der apple boy scp actions
add master ich weiß nicht ob add master so clever ist vielleicht ist besser wenn man
dann eine version in version stack hardcode reinschreibt dann weil wenn es add master
ist dann gehen auf mein dann gehen auf einmal alle meine integri also alle meine jobs kaputt
wenn wenn apple boy irgendwie komische sachen macht
hast du dieses code inside zeug von github schon getestet nee
ok kopieren wir uns das mal da ober hin viel mehr müssen wir da wahrscheinlich nicht
machen so und jetzt source source ist was source ist da muss ich noch mal gucken source
ist gebildet hat er hier da ok was das das mussten wir das letzte mal kopieren das da
ok source source so das kopieren wir auf den server unter dem target test
tribulon fünf monate dankeschön so also wir kopieren das jetzt
wir kopieren jetzt unseren publish folder auf den server in den ordner test wenn das
so funktioniert wie ich mir das vorstelle probieren wir mal aus komm mit gehen wir mal
auf den server drauf per ssh werden mal der user den wird der wir sein müssen und gucken
ob da was rauskommt am ende ok jetzt wird erstmal der apple boy gebildet
der installiertes halbe internet um scp hin zu können dann nicht in ernst jetzt ich muss
mal gucken ob ich das in irgendein schell kommando rein kriege ob ich irgendwie mein ssh key
da selbst in scp hauen kann oder so das ist doch der witz es fehlt bloß noch dass ich
eine note anwendung ne view app oder so hätte und erst mal da müsste ich erstmal ja installieren
und erstmal note installiert dann ja installiert oh je es ist kaputt gegangen oder was war
das alle verschmerzen all files in tubla mt archive
man kann hier auch direkt schell kommandos ausführen aber ich müsste mein ssh ich müsste
irgendwie auf ssh key zugreifen können dass ich in scp machen kann wisst ihr was wir mal
ausprobieren ob mein ssh key nicht ne mein ssh key liegt da bestimmt nicht im file der
steht doch bestimmt in den n variables ja da müsste ich aber erstmal gucken wie man
es scp beibringt den key zu verwenden der in irgendwelchen environment variablen steht
das geht nämlich so ohne weiteres gar nicht ich weiß noch dass ich da vor ein paar jahren
mal ein riesen ag gemacht habe dass das funktioniert also ssh und scp kann standardmäßig außer
per ssh agent kann nichts von standard in lesen und nichts aus environment variablen
ich glaube aus pipes liest auch nichts äh moment warum ist jetzt warum ging es jetzt
eigentlich nicht weil ich den falschen ordner angegeben habe das können wir danach probieren
ich gucke jetzt erstmal dass ich meinen kram deployed kriege der irgendwie hier liegt so
im tita weil ich wahrscheinlich ich gebe jetzt mal das komplette verzeichnis an mal gucken
das muss ja zumindest jetzt gehen und jetzt können wir zugucken was er macht hier live
ich meine auf der anderen seite ohne scheiß leute 11 sekunden set up sind verkraftbar
oder gibt schlimmeres oh ich sehe es just play das jetzt leute der punkt ist nicht zentriert
im lade icon das triggert mich jetzt auch schon alter wo ist das problem mt mt ag warum
ist das mt es mich rollen oder was warum geht das nicht man ks muss man vielleicht das
so angeben ohne ohne das letzte ohne das letzte
kann das sein dass der die action ausführt bevor das andere fertig ist
die sind sequenziell ok aber den ordner muss es geben ich meine ich habe den der zeigt
den ergibt den doch auch aus
der dort auch klar kann es den ordner angeben so ist es
hat das bild funktioniert
das haben wir doch hier
jetzt weiß ich nicht was der verschmerzen hat warum das ganze nicht funktioniert
ich meine was man was soll ich da großartig anderes angeben da trailing slash
und sie soll zwar ohne hatte ich eben mit oder ohne slash
wahrscheinlich hat er wirklich ein problem mit dem slash
wahrscheinlich müsste ich dann so was hier machen
da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt wenn das an dem slash liegt
dann wäre das eindeutig ziemlich keck weh
ich weiß der satz hat weh getan aber es wäre trotzdem ziemlich keck weh
und leute der punkt ist nicht zentriert das können wir jetzt nicht mehr nicht mehr
ignorieren nachdem was einmal gesehen haben
wenn das liegt wenn das stp dann liegt das wahrscheinlich wirklich an dem slash
achtung leute jetzt hier copy
was wo ist das problem man
macht er da
das sieht mir nicht richtig aus oder wisst ihr wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen wir machen
jetzt big brain time absolut massive big brain time
wir machen jetzt einfach
stern rein wir kopieren einfach alles und gucken ob es funktioniert
nein wir kopieren jetzt alles
ich meine das bild funktioniert ja
sonst würde er hier nicht sagen er konnte bilden
erst mal alles erst mal alles tarn
so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt easy das funktioniert
das funktioniert okay gucken wir mal ob hier was angekommen ist ordner test ordner test
wo ist mein bild
ich bin bestimmt ich bin im falschen verzeichnis
aber wie kann ich im falschen verzeichnis sein
ist wahrscheinlich im publish nein er ist nicht im publish folder folder wenn er im
publish folder wäre da würde da wären jetzt hier
das zeug zum ausführen das ist das ganz normale
in welchem verzeichnis ist der denn
okay okay okay weiter weiter also
ich meine was es muss doch gehen es muss doch gehen dass ich sowas hier mache
warte mal das da das muss doch funktionieren
copy das da so safe
ja ich wollte passow wechseln spielen
aber ich bin immer noch nicht unschlüssig ich bin immer noch unschlüssig was ich spielen
soll
ich ja ich habe ich habe fast den eindruck dass meine reinfolge ein bisschen ein bisschen
kaputt ist
das ist ein checker und master
stimmt ach nee das gehört dazu
nee was ist das
wo kommt das hier her
moment das was macht das was macht das checker und master davor
das gehört hier oben dazu
warte mal
das moment das gehört dazu
und das das hat er doch überhaupt nichts zu suchen
der überschreibt das der überschreibt das glaube ich einfach
der bildet das und das checker überschreibt das wahrscheinlich dann was auch immer das
dann
wo kommt das überhaupt her
zum glück braucht es nicht so lange zum glück habe ich vor allem zum glück habe ich 2000
stunden äh 2000 minuten
microsoft live troll auf twitter
alter warum ist das problem
ich verstehe wo ist wo hat er was hat er denn jetzt verschmerzt so kompliziert kann er
kann doch nicht sein
ich weiß leute ich sag euch ich ich sag euch woran es liegt ich
jetzt bin ich ich hab ich hab eine idee ich hab eine idee woran es liegt
ähm
also von der idee her vom ablauf her stimmt das doch
der macht ein check out der macht ein bild der macht ein bild
und dann kopiert er nicht
ich gebe hier mal eine version an
ich gebe hier mal die letzte release version an
um mal auszuschließen dass die version von dieser action kaputt ist
so
ok den kram machen wir warte mal der kram kommt weg
da kann ich kann ich viel passieren so
so und dann will ich den den mist will ich kopieren
source
löscht er danach irgendwas oder so
net version kann ich abweglassen ich will einfach die neueste
wow fuck einfach einfach die neueste
ich kann jetzt erstmal kein ls machen das ist ja kein kein kein terminal oder so
da müsste ich jetzt erstmal gucken wie ich da kommandos ausführen oder kann man hier
einfach
oder nee das ist wahrscheinlich ein stink normales wie führen kommando aus tun
also sprich wie ging das hier mit nem ein pipe
so
hier und danach und danach noch mal
weiß ja nie so genau
ich mein der macht nen check out der macht nen check out
der set up dot net core
wir machen wir machen mal die neueste wir machen mal die neueste version hier
machen da mal
eins
punkt vier punkten null
so und danach ist zp mal ich mein da kann da kann doch jetzt echt nicht viel schief
gehen bei der ganzen geschichte
so und den letzten slash war mal auch mal weg
port
war mal noch mal hier komport port wobei das eigentlich jetzt damit nichts zu tun haben
sollte
port 22
das hat man glaube ich ganz am anfang oder hatte ich das nicht ganz als gar als allererstes
drin und ich hab grad alles kopiert und da war der bild nicht dabei
aha aha
da ist es das war die version die aktuelle version von dem von dem von der action ist
verbugged
die master version von der action ist verbugged
ja das hier das hier war es bestimmt
oder das hier eins von beiden was anderes habe ich doch nicht gemacht oder oder habe
ich irgendwas vorher gemacht
ich habe zwei sachen gerne ich habe die ich habe hier eine feste version reingeschrieben
und hier eine feste version reingeschrieben
und was was gibt er hier eigentlich als
ich mach da nicht wieder master rein ich lasse das jetzt so
so pbd was gibt er noch aus
ja
action
nice den checkout habe ich aber davor schon rausgelöscht das hat nichts gebracht
so und jetzt können wir das ssh ding wieder rein machen
und hier geben wir auch noch mal ein port an weil weil es so schön ist port 22
ne cheste das nicht nochmals das lasse ich jetzt so
so
was ich jetzt natürlich ein bisschen komisch finde ist
muss ich das jetzt wirklich so
also ich bin guck mal ich bin ja schon da drinnen
ich bin ja schon da drinnen das heißt ich kann jetzt wirklich das machen was ich ursprünglich
auch vor hatte
nämlich nur den daneben
hoffentlich funktioniert das was könnte sein es könnte sein dass das verzeichnis zwischen
jedem
zwischen jedem schritt resettet wird das könnte das könnte sein
das weiß ich nicht das mal ausprobieren
da der ordner davor nicht github auf auf dem zielserver schon ja
punkt slash punkt slash ist genau das gleiche wie einfach nix davor schreiben
ja funktioniert
ja bin funktioniert sehr schön ok kann man dem ding noch irgendwie sagen dass
der dass der clear machen soll oder so remove remove
ja am am auf true dass sie schöner löscht an den kram vorher das bin ich das da bin
ich dabei
das finde ich gut dass das soll er ruhig mal machen
löscht den kram
so und jetzt wird es auch noch mal spannend jetzt ist die frage wie kriege ich mein server
gestartet also sprich der deploys das ganze unter test
test bin wobei kommen wir nennen es jetzt nicht test wir nennen es app
irgendwas in der richtung app test bin publish
gut das probieren wir jetzt mal aus also sprich per essers ha
ok das muss ich jetzt anders da probieren weil ich kann mich von meinem von meinem
von meiner ledungskiste nur als root anmelden und nicht als stream
da muss ich jetzt mal lokal ausprobieren
so also was will ich machen ich will mich einloggen ich will dahin cd machen
und dann will ich was will ich denn eigentlich machen
das ding starten also sprich das da will ich machen
allerdings will ich das ganze detached machen
also sprich mal sowas vielleicht muss ich das mit nohub machen
kannst du den ordnerwurst daraus nehmen dass er direkt zu app kopiert ja das müsste auch
funktionieren
da muss ich wahrscheinlich vorher noch ein cd machen
also ich denke mal wenn ich hier ein cd machen würde
das probieren wir danach aus das probieren wir danach aus wenn es funktioniert
also ich denke mal wenn ich hier ein cd mache
nach dahin und dann nur publish kopieren müsste eigentlich auch funktionieren
das cd wird resettet
dann müssen wir uns das plug in nochmal angucken das probieren wir danach aus
ich will diese feature für gettya oder gettya haben
ich habe bei mir ja auch lokal getty laufen aber
ich hatte da bis jetzt noch nie das bedürfnis also sprich wenn ich irgendwas lokal bilden
will dann installiere ich mir irgendwas halt
entweder den jankins oder den drone oder sonst was
aber es wäre schon cool auf jeden fall oder den gitlab oder so
ich darf jetzt nicht so viel auf einmal ändern weil sonst funktioniert der ganze kram wieder
nicht
ich kopiere das dahin so ach nee ich wollte ja gucken wie ich die app starte
so also so starten wir die app wenn ich jetzt so mache dann geht die app wahrscheinlich
aus wenn ich mich aus logge denke ich mal
ja also muss ich das wahrscheinlich mit no hab ich meine ich könnte auch in dem ich könnte
auch im t-mark starten ich werde definitiv kein system die unit file dafür basteln oder
sowas
also no hab vielleicht sowas hier nach keine ahnung log file punkt txt und dann so
was btf ansaft akko tils da ist ja nix drauf ja
ach mit p ich kacke noob ja
ach mit p ja
hub no hub
so wenn man jetzt hier reingucken müsste man den log sehen
kann es sein dass es schon läuft
das muss ich auch noch ich muss das alte programm noch abschießen
jetzt läuft ok also das müssen wir starten
ok also das heißt
das heißt übrigens das log machen wir nicht nach log file sondern nach erst mal nach
tmp
gucken gut also was von der idee wie müssen wir das machen als erstes muss ich mal als
erstes muss ich killen
als erstes muss ich killen danach wir machen jetzt richtig mir fällt gerade nichts besseres
ein ja so danach wir killen also wir killen das alte programm dann warten wir 15 sekunden
und dann starten wir das neue und vorher müssen wir in das ding hier rein das passende verzeichnis
rein
so jetzt gucken wir ob das funktioniert also der sollte jetzt beim push den kram auch ich
lösche das mal dass man auch sieht dass es funktioniert
so mit netstat gucken wir mal ob was läuft nee läuft nicht ok
und save schauen was er jetzt macht action
bin ich jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert weil ich das zusammen gewusstet
habe
das geht definitiv wenn man sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt hat gar nicht das triggert
mich so dass dieser lade balken nicht in der mitte ist der punkt das ist so so cannot
an sie so das hat man jetzt einmal gesehen und ich kann es nicht mehr nicht mehr nicht
sehen jetzt
übrigens morgen früh wieder aufwacht streben
würdest du so was wie ein user was o x ist das user interface design studium empfehlen
ich habe kein schimmer viele grüße aus südkorea
viele grüße zurück nach südkorea und viele munt schütze
ich habe gehört in südkorea braucht man die genauso wie hier
ok hat kopiert
aber das hatte nicht gestartet
warum nicht ich habe es umbenannt in app leute ich habe es verkackt ich habe es in app umbenannt
das hätte mir auch mal sagen können das hättet ihr mir auch mal sagen können ansonsten immer
hart am backseat programm in der chat und solche sachen sagt mir keiner
haben wir hier sonst so irgendwas ne passt
jetzt ist zu spät
das ist das ist der billigste 5 euro im monat server ich glaube ich habe diesen monat und
man bezahlt ja auch ein bisschen nach usage ich habe diesen monat glaube ich 98 cent server
kosten gab bei digital ocean 98 cent huge huge money
offer deutschland wird nicht mit dem virus über das hoffe ich auch
no process found ist ok no process found ist in ordnung es lief ja auch gerade nicht
ok jetzt es läuft es funktioniert leute
ich gebe zu eine schöne geschichte ist es jetzt nicht die ich hier gestrickt habe ich
meine das mal gucken was wir was wir hier machen ich mein wir checken das git repo aus
wir bilden unsere dotnet core applikation wir szp ist auf den server rüber und und starten
die sache auf dem server eigentlich so schlecht ist es doch gar nicht ich meine das hier ist
kein das ist keine schöne sache mein besser wäre es ich hätte ein ordentliches start
start skipp oder eventuell sogar ein system die unit oder so was dafür aber es gibt gibt
das wir wollen jetzt mal nicht so anspruchsvoll sein so wir wollten noch eine sache ausprobieren
oder was das eins hat wir wollten noch ein paar sachen machen als erstes habe ich jetzt
noch mal eine weitere high IQ idee und zwar das log file das nennen wir nach dem aktuellen
datum weil aktuell na so jetzt heißt das log file einfach nur log file was ein bisschen
doof ist weil ich habe keine ahnung wann das angelegt wurde deswegen nennen wir das log
file date und dann plus date format plus prozent f glaube ist das was ist das format für time
einfach t easy f prozent t underscore so das machen wir jetzt das hauen wir dann noch rein
dann heißt nämlich auch unser log unsere log datei richtig ja also das mit den masken
ist so eine sache ich habe ja ich habe ja eine riesenfette maske habe ich ja schon mal
gezeigt ich habe mir eine riesenfette maske gekauft man das hier mal irgendwie aber die
habe ich mir die habe ich mir nicht gekauft für corona die hatte ich mir schon davor
gekauft für wenn ich daheim schimmel wegmachen muss zu hause oder staub oder sonst was was
nicht so gesund ist aber jetzt ist praktisch jetzt kann man sowas gebrauchen so ok das
hier wollten wir noch ausprobieren wenn ich wenn ich cd dahin mache ob ich dann einfach
nur sagen kann publish das probieren wir jetzt mal ob das ob das klappt dann geht aber hier
unten das geht auf jeden fall jetzt gleich kaputt aber wir sehen ob ob ob das prinzipiell
geht wenn ich mal das wieder rückgängig ich ganz ehrlich ich fände es nicht verkehrt
wenn die leute im zug ich feier auch morgens immer mit mit dem zug zur arbeit ich fände
es nicht schlecht wenn die leute im zug alle eine maske aufziehen würden der tweet ist
gut ich fände es gut er näher nicht geklappt nicht das wird resettet so und jetzt zeige
ich euch noch mal geht geht hack source also hier haben wir zeug committed was man wieder
rauslöschen wollen so und wir wollen auf das kommet davor man kann resetten entweder
direkt hier auf den tag oder man sagt einfach geht reset minus minus minus minus hart und
dann sagt man hätte eins zurück man sieht jetzt sind wir hier gerade auf 0 b 4 und danach
sind wir auf dem davor gehts weil hätte es immer einen zeiger auf das letzte kommet
in geht und die tilde ist immer vom letzten kommet 1 zurück man kann übrigens auch sowas
hier machen das geht auch jede tilde ist ein kommet warum weil weil weil weil die sich
das so ausgedacht haben weil linus dachte so ist das gute gute befehl
du hast ja ein server warum hast du nicht an einen github server ich habe daheim und
ich will ja auch nur ausprobieren das zeug funktionieren aber sowas habe ich halt am
liebsten nicht bei mir laufen weil um so wenig ich meine es kostet ja nichts um so weniger
ich das bei mir stehen habe umso besser bei uns auf der arbeit kannst eigentlich gar
kein erzählen bei uns auf der arbeit haben die leute klopapier und das infektionsmittel
geklaut aus dem klo und aus dem vorrats aus aus dem vorratsschrank aus der vorratskammer
wo nur die putzfrau rein kann normalerweise da siehst du mal wie verzweifelt die leute
mittlerweile sind auf der arbeit erstmal klopapier klauen so und jetzt gucken wir mal nach temp
rein ach ich noob jetzt habe ich ja auch jetzt habe ich ja auch meine big brain änderung
meine massive brain änderung aus dem logfile rückgängig gemacht aber ich denke so funktioniert
das sollte jetzt das machen was wir wollen er checkt das repo aus er bildet die dotnet
anwendung er kopiert den kamper scp rüber beendet die alte anwendung startet die neue
anwendung ist doch wunderbar wie lange hast du noch home office wie gesagt letzte woche
war ich ja daheim weil es mir im haus gegratzt hat und hat mein chef gesagt bleibt bloß
weg aber also wäre das jetzt korona gewesen dann dann hätte ich jetzt wahrscheinlich
andere probleme ja sowas hier finny sowas bräuchten wir auch ich verstehe eh nicht warum
aber unsere regierung ist da nicht so schnell die brauchen mit allem fünf jahre ich fände
es auch sehr sinnvoll wenn man gesagt hätte jetzt wo sich das ganze schon andeutet ja
also jetzt wo sich das abzeichnet dass dass wir auch davon betroffen sein könnten dass
man dann entweder gesagt hätte wir verteilen kostenlos maskenhandschuhe desinfektionsmittel
oder aber dass man eben geguckt hätte dass die versorgung insoweit aufrechterhalten wird
dass nicht jetzt irgendwie leute 8000 masken kaufen können aber wir sind bei sowas ultra
langsam ich meine ich habe es vor ich habe es vorhin erzählt die fallzahlen wurden wurden
angeblich bis freitag noch per brief gemeldet per brief im jahr 2020 also das seid ihr
in korea garantiert schon weiter per brief muss man sich mal vorstellen per post
und guck hier unser neues logfile ist am start nice funktioniert sehr schön mal gucken ob
auch der request drin steht gucken ob auch der request drin steht wenn ich da wenn ich
da ich ach so wir müssen ja das noch von extern leute wir wollen wir das noch von extern
erreichbar machen den service dass ihr alle einmal im browser hallo welt abrufen könnt
das das muss glaube ich sein hallo welt muss muss ihr wolltet schon immer mal hallo hallo
world as a service haben
hallo world as a service ok da ok einfach request gibt da nicht aus na ok
auslastest können wir mal machen wir gucken dann wir gucken dann was das ding was das ding
für die auslastung also aktuell hat es null ok dann machen wir das ganze mal von extern
von extern erreichbar also was ich was ich ganz gerne nehme dafür ist also ich meine
die app die app läuft jetzt also die die app läuft jetzt hier und bei jedem bei jedem
push ins git repo das probieren wir jetzt mal aus ob das funktioniert noch mal noch mal
endgültig so ich bin auch später schon master hier hoch pullen noch mal so gehen ich mache
mal meine history wieder ein bisschen ordentlich ups fuck machen wir mal die ganzen ganzen
schmodder hier weg den ich da committert habe gehen wir wieder dahin status alles noch
drin so wie es sein soll jetzt force pushen wir das ganze so und jetzt sollte der eigentlich
sich einloggen und ohne dass ich was mache ohne dass ich hier drum klicke einen neuen
job anwerfen und die sache auf den server deployen das sehen wir auch daran wenn wir
jetzt hier gucken das log file müsste gleich ein neues entstehen so um um 44 oder so ja
deutschland ist eine ganze ecke hinterher wenn zum intern ausbau geht ich meine ich
habe letztens was gelesen in südkorea da ist ja teilweise gigabit schon fast standard
bei uns freuen die sich wenn sie mal wenn sie es mal hinkriegen dass alle leute 50
mitbekommen da sind die richtig weiter dran ok er kopiert er kopiert noch er führt aus
der breitband atlas ist immer lustig ja ok alles fertig da ist es 44 habe ich doch gut
geschätzt oder so und jetzt machen wir das ganze von extern erreichbar was ich immer
gerne mache für für kleine seiten die im internet erreichbar sein müssen und wo die
anwendung selber weder authentifizierung hat noch irgendwie sonst irgendwie mit mit sicherheit
im kopf programmiert wurde da stellt man da stelle ich immer ganz gern einen proxy
irgendeiner art davor normalerweise wenn das irgendwas ist was ich quasi schon schon länger
betreiben beziehungsweise länger betreiben will dann mache ich dann engine extra vor
normalerweise aber für so klein scheiß finde ich den hier fast am besten weil das coole
daran ist dass der komplett wir haben leider keine domain sonst könnte ich euch das sonst
könnte ich euch direkt mal überlegt hat kann ich kann ich das haben wir eigentlich von
ping easy einer ping ich überlege mal ich überlege mal ob ich es schafft irgendwie
eine domain auf das ding zu kriegen ich habe ich habe doch eine domain wartet mal ich habe
doch ich habe doch hier progas x y z ist progas x y z das bin ich so kommt man da raus wenn
man progas aufmacht bei meinem registrar ok ich ich lege mal ich lege mannen record an
für den server jeder können wir das ganze nämlich direkt mit hatte tps let's encrypt
und und und richtiger domain machen aber dazu muss ich mich erst einmal auf dem zweiten
rechner einloggen bei meinem domain register typ und den record anlegen sein in das dauert
jetzt kurz in der zwischenzeit dürft ihr euch fischer angucken weil das will ich nicht
im stream machen ok wie macht man hier dns einträge so wie
machen wir dns einträge die seite ist ein bisschen ein bisschen wir aufgebaut da finde
ich mich immer nicht zurecht wo macht man hier bei diesem komischen domain registrar
hier dns records so was machen wir was machen wir uns für eine domain wir machen einfach
stream hier stream punkt progas punkt x y machen wir einfach wenn a record auf proger progas
und zwar mit dieser ip so dann gucken wir ob das ganze klappt diese ip add gut ist hinzugefügt
so warten bis er dns refreshed ist und dann sehen wir es das dauert zwei drei minuten
das geht meistens ziemlich schnell
das geht meistens ziemlich schnell aber wir müssen kurz warten bis der dns refreshed
ist und dann kann ich euch zeigen so richtig mit
jetzt mal langsam aber sicher hier mal so zu ich lösche einfach mal die ganzen anderen
übrig gebliebenen records die brauche keiner mehr perfekt ich müsste man dns cache noch
lernen machen es aber dick ok die dns aber refreshen gerade nicht so sonderlich geschwind
das müssen wir kurz kurz abwarten dann zeige ich euch wie das ganze funktioniert relativ
easy das ist eine schöne sache wenn den eigenen server hat bietet sich das auch an
aber mein lock na gut meine auflösung lokal hat noch den anderen server drin gecasht
wie dem auch sei an sich funktioniert die auflösung das heißt wenn ihr stream progress
x y z macht sollte die auf dieser ip rauskommen so das heißt was wir jetzt machen können
nachdem das von externer funktioniert der lock ab ich nehme ganz gerne den server hierfür
für so klein für so klein kram ist wunderbar ist total simpel und hat letztendlich kript
eingebaut jetzt machen wir natürlich das was alle gerne machen und zwar
genau wir peipen einfach mal was nach bash so wie es sich so wie es sich gehört so wie
man das so wie man das natürlich nicht macht ach so ich muss ja personal oder so auf einem
öffentlichen server muss dann immer install server install natürlich natürlich klar
was sonst also das coole ist der server braucht keine rootrechte oder sonst irgendwas und
ich werde euch jetzt mal zeigen wie easy die config datei ist die ist mega einfach die
ist wirklich mega einfach einfacher könnt ihr kein einfacher könnt ihr kein ssl zertifikat
ok ich habe nichts gesagt man braucht auch gut na dann kann ich auch systemweit installieren
ich dachte eigentlich man braucht kein root ok man braucht auch kein root man braucht
auch kein root ich glaube ich könnte auch das binary einfach runterladen das würde
so funktionieren aber wie dem auch sei es egal wie er den surfer beziehungsweise wie
die anwendung bei euch auf den surfer drauf kriegt ist ja wurscht so was wir jetzt machen
können ist wir haben jetzt das ding hier und das startet jetzt aber hat er noch er hat
er noch keine config file das heißt ich lege jetzt einfach einen cuti file an und kopieren
wir hier mal den kram rein so also meine domain ist stream punkt progers punkt x y z basic
aus ich vertraue dem chat lasse ich raus so und das ganze proxied auf port 5000 und ich
glaube das war's mehr braucht man nicht wir gucken noch mal ob meine anwendung läuft
jetzt das da ist er so und jetzt starte ich einfach cuti email adresse lassen wir leer
und der geht jetzt zuletzt ein kript holt sich ein zertifikat das dauert kurz und
dann ist unter stream progers punkt x y z der nix der hi end hello world service am start
sobald er hier durch ist
moment kann das sein
ok hier achtung leute
easy oder eats eats af also einfacher geht das ganze nicht sondern jetzt guckt mal ob
ihr das ding irgendwie ausgelastet kriegt
haut mal drauf der hello world service muss abstürzen leute
let's go
wie viel cpu kerne haben wir einen komm das werde ich auch hinkriegen sieht gut aus sieht
gut aus noch überhaupt kein problem weiter bäm gib ihm gib ihm stream progas punkt x
also chat
ich bin ich bin enttäuscht
schon 20 tabs offen ja mit tabs wird man da nicht so viel nicht so weit kommen denke
ich da muss man schon irgendwas mal anschmeißen was ein bisschen mehr verbindung macht
da gibt es doch dieses wie ist das dieses apache dieses apache webserver benchmark
ding ist richtig ist den aus erlaubt nee weil ich keinen bock habe das digital außen bei
mir nervt dass ich irgendwie hier dazu aufrufen würde ihren service land zu legen
gut wunderbar apache web benchmark gab es noch so einen webseiten benchmark benchmark
war das das ding hier warum digital außen keine hetzer klauen weil ich einen digital
außen account habe und ich schnell ins server gebraucht habe so hier apache benchmark anzahl
der kleinen verbindung anzahl der anfangen welche ausgeführt werden 200 ok wir machen
jetzt wir machen jetzt den apache benchmark hier fort also habe ich das tool überhaupt
installiert nee was muss ich überhaupt installieren apache bench apache 2 utils
die gibt es nicht apache tools das wäre natürlich auch zu einfach das wäre auch viel zu einfach
wenn der kram gleich heißen würde viel zu einfach wenn das wenn das überall gleich
heißen würde wo kämen wir denn dahin
erstmal noch mal selbst kompilieren wir sind ja unterliegungs erst mal richtig zeigen dass
wir dich die hacker man sind es oh nee nee das ist ab mit live will ich nicht keck wehe
also attps stream punkt punkt roger's punkt x y z falsch warum ist das falsch ah wie
kann man den wie kann man den jetzt schön schön mal auslasten hier was machen wir also
wie viele requests sind was vielleicht eine verbindung 20 anzahl der anfangen welche
ok und jetzt kann man eben noch irgendwie sagen sekunden oder was war das macht er
jetzt was ah jetzt geht ein bisschen hoch ok also 200 gleichzeitig verbindung und dann
200.000 da bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen jetzt also da geht da geht aber da geht aber
noch ein bisschen was also das gar nicht so einfach das den kram auszulasten wie kann
man da jetzt mal ordentlich last produzieren was war das minus t time limit minus t ok
also sagen wir minus t minus t und dann irgendwie jetzt mal zehn sekunden zehn sekunden ok
da wirklich viel gemacht hat es jetzt nicht also wie viel wie viel wie viele konne wie
viele haben wir jetzt eigentlich dahin gekriegt 459 was 459 requests in in zehn sekunden das
ist ja armselig das ist ja nix oder pro sekunde oder pro sekunde ok komm mal was da rauskommt
guck mal er macht was er versucht zu multithreaden was auf einer cpu natürlich jetzt nicht so
gut funktioniert was sagt mir das hier hat er wirklich zehn sekunden nur wie viele wie
viele requests per second request 51 requests per second das ist aber nicht viel oder fünf
sekunden lang mit irgendwie zehn parallel da braucht man kein cloudflare mehr so jetzt
haben wir requests per second 17 ok machen wir mal mit 2000 parallelen verbindung in
your face so viel darf ich nicht machen 1000 da muss ich wahrscheinlich root werden vorher
rechtes darf dann schaffen wir das das könnte meiner vm vielleicht liegen nur gut ich krieg
das ding nicht ordentlich ausgelastet aber wir haben das geschafft was wir schaffen
wollten ich mache jetzt wieder aus also hier den ding haben das geschafft was verschaffen
wollten automatisches deployment über geht funktionieren also über github funktioniert
ganz gut ich meine einen super einen großartigen preis für das dafür werden wir jetzt nicht
gewinnen ich meine vor allem das hier zum starten und stoppen der app ist und ziemlich
billig wo bloß tv ist hinter cloudflare super das unglaublich wichtig dass es hinter cloudflare
ist vor allem wenn die video selbst auf google drive liegen so gibt es noch irgendwas soll
man noch irgendwas ausprobieren also ich habe erst mal eigentlich ganz gut eindruckt davon
was gibt es denn sonst noch so für actions lass mal gucken was gibt es denn alles noch
was gibt es denn sonst noch hier alles action was haben die denn hier zu bieten also wir
haben schon mal 2680 actions kann man die sortieren nach sternen warum kann man das nicht nach
sternen sortieren filters das ist ja das einzige bei github was ich kenne was man nicht nach
sternen sortieren was jetzt für ein schwachsinn warum kann man die action nicht nach sternen
sortieren bescheuert dass man gleich mal sieht was beliebt ist was haben die hier zum beispiel
unter monitoring so zu bieten remote bash ja klingt nach wahnsinnig viel monitoring
finde ich echt doof dass man das nicht sortieren kann nach nach github filters sort stars nicht
filters actions kann man hier mit der suche irgendwas machen irgendwie in der suche sagt
actions das ist ja doof was kann das ding zum beispiel alles deployen das nervt mich
habe ich jetzt keinen bock drauf zu gucken wenn man das nicht nach sternen sortieren
kann ist das doof das sagt verified okay das sind nur die offiziellen aber warum gibt
es keine verified actions ich dachte es sind zumindest noch nicht mal die offiziellen githubs
sind verified unverified unverified gibt es auch nichts okay der filter funktioniert
einfach nicht ich frage mich gerade ob es die möglichkeit gibt dass man das man bilds
dass man das irgendwie käscht oder so also sprich dass ich dass ich beispielsweise na
gut ich habe jetzt keine ich habe jetzt keine großartigen dependencies die ich cashen müsste
das lohnt sich jetzt gar nicht topics github actions findet man da alles heißt mal was
oben rechts cash wo ach hier ja aber ich habe nix was ich cashen könnte hier falls mir
zu spät eingefallen so github actions most stars run your github actions locally na das
ist doch was es hat auch vorhin einer gesagt er würde gerne den kram bei sich bei sich
lokal laufen lassen da könnt ihr github action bei euch lokal laufen lassen wobei ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht verstehe warum der vorteil bei mir ist also der vorteil für mich ist ja quasi
gerade dass es nicht bei mir läuft qa wolf hat tests warum leute warum warum sollte man
test schreiben guter kod dokumentiert sich selbst und außerdem wozu braucht man tests
wenn man perfekt programmiert easy so also der qa wolf ist ein kod dokumentiert
der qa wolf den brauche ich auch nicht wirklich
ach das ist so ein ding was was web browser da hat aber einer hier seine gif kennt seine
gif skills walten lassen das gif sieht ja echt jenseits von gut und böse aus guckt
euch das immer an wir hatten das gif erstellt war eine güde das sieht nicht gut aus was
ist also ich möchte selten mein router betriebssystem jeden tag neu bilden
action toolkit ja die habe ich schon gewusst habe ich gerade gesehen die liste erst mal
nach github actions in node.js github pages p.a.p. jetzt kommen sie aber alle hier alle
die kommen sie aus ihren löchern jetzt home automation github actions was es nicht alles
gibt home assistant command das heißt ich kann ich kann wenn ich ein git commit mache
kann ich in meinem büro das licht anschalten ah yes excellent automatisierung das brauche
exquisite wenn ich immer wenn ich ein git push mache dann blinkt mein licht im büro
das ist doch mal was exquisite ja perfekt welches ist deine lieblings distribution desktop
oder server exzellent ja richtig exzellent automatisch rebase pull requests das ist eigentlich
ganz gut wieder ein weiterer grund dass man master nicht rebaste und funktioniert das
nicht server also das was ich am meisten verwende ist halt notgedrungen red hat aber am liebsten
auf dem server habe ich ubuntu server ubuntu server ist mir am liebsten auch wenn man halt
so enterprise mäßig zum größten teil red hat geschichten hat und teilweise oracle kram
noch sowas hier hast du eigentlich hast du eigentlich mit dem friseur noch kontakt ja
klar was ist das teammate ist ist da war doch irgendwie so ein t max für für zum session
scheren der apple boy da ist es die haben wir auch verwendet geht es ist t plus plus
leute pain tut weh ich habe den schon paar mal genervt dass wir was zusammen machen aber
da hat kein bock mal auf youtube ich ja aktuell auch nicht aber morgen leute morgen gibt es
das battlefield top play video was sind actions das kann ich dir jetzt hier das kann ich jetzt
hier ganz gut zeigen an das was wir gemacht haben man kann sich in seinem github repo
einen workflow andere einrichten habe ich habe heute morgen den webcast dazu gesehen
also so konferenz talk deswegen bin ich heute auf die idee gekommen ist mal auszuprobieren
und da kann man sich dann ein kriegt man ja mal feilen kann man sich workflow definieren
zum beispiel ein workflow der bei jedem pusch bei jedem geht pusch das repo auscheckt die
anwendung baut und dann die anwendung rüber scp auf den server sich per ssh einloggt
und die anwendung die alte anwendung stoppt und die neue anwendung startet was ist an
z plus plus so schlimm erzähl mal habe ich doch schon so oft ich habe mich doch schon
so oft über z plus plus ausgelassen und da warst und herz 390 da warst du auch dabei
das weiß ich
die projekte scheinen sehr beliebt zu sein fast api und dann ist das ganze in pyson
programmiert entdecke den fehler oder meinen die mit fast nicht dass die anwendung schnell
ist sondern dass das dass man es schnell implementieren kann flutter action twitter da kann ich da
kann ich auf twitter posten jungs habe ein neues kommet so blöd ist das gar nicht wenn
man teams hat oder so da kann man dann bei jedem kommet da was hin posten wobei aber
halt auch jeder teams hat ja auch eine github integration ok man kann ein neues release
bauen lassen alles schön und gut
wann kommt endlich der alles falsch mit z plus plus stream habe nie gesagt dass ich alles
falsch mit z plus plus machen wie gesagt ich habe ja mittlerweile ein riesen text dokument
wo drin steht was mir an z plus plus auf den sack geht für den fall der fälle dass mal
leute das immer wissen weil die leute wollen das immer wissen wenn ich über z plus plus
merke was ich so scheiße an z plus plus finde ich meine ich muss aber nicht jede woche fünf
mal erzählen deswegen habe ich schon langes tech aber ich mache dazu keine extra stream
wozu wer z plus plus verwenden will das hat natürlich auch seine anwendungszwecke ja
beispielsweise in mein ganze microcontroller arduino geschichten und sps die sind ja auch
z plus plus gezwungenermaßen aber sobald man anfängt sich näher mit z plus plus zu
beschäftigen muss man quasi jeden jede zweite minute kotzen wenn man irgendwas sieht
execute any script in github issue comment what warum um alles in der welt sollte ich
random scripts aus einem github issue comment ausführen da ist ja sicherheit vor programmiert
und wo ist die liste bei mir auf dem rechner modernes cross site script ja schon telegram
action go releaser action workflow das ist workflow das haben wir noch gerade schon mal
ja was auch immer dann haben wir hier latex action ok ist jetzt nicht so spannend sich
den kram anzugucken das ist natürlich praktisch wenn man einen ssh agent haben dann könnte
ich meine scp so ein ssh komando selbst das ist gut da bräuchte ich nämlich diese ganzen
anderen dinger nicht mehr das ist sogar noch viel besser das ist fast das ist fast viel
angenehmer ja einfach hier ssh agent und danach kann ich kann ich kopieren was ich will mit
ssh da brauche ich diese anderen diese anderen actions gar nicht mehr das ist gut das gefällt
mir das ist auch bescheuert das spruch stand ja gerade hier oben irgendwo bei einem komisch
das ist bescheuert das spruch das ist so so so so so haffbefehl reiben gut also funktioniert
alles gut sehr nice was ist das für eine vm äh was ist das für ein window manager und
ein terminal emulator das ist i3 und als terminal ist ein ganz normales gnome gnome terminal
soll dann wisst ihr was ich jetzt mache mit meiner digital außen vm weg damit kostet
nur geld also wie gesagt i3 wm und und gnome terminal und das repo löschen wir auch weil
hallo die hallo world api da hat die welt jetzt wirklich nicht drauf gewartet die kostet
geld wenn die aus ist ich weiß ich werde die nachher löschen wenn ich um gelockt bin
so
leute gibt es noch was wichtiges wenn ich gehe ich jetzt was futtern
weil morgen früh bin ich ich schon wieder am start morgen früh wie immer so gegen keine
ahnung zehn halb zehn kurz nach zehn irgendwie so wann ich war nicht wach bin
was drei euro vierundvierzig würde ein 1,6 terabyte backup kosten könnte man machen
aber ganz ehrlich warum warum warum braucht man dann brauchen wir den back ab das ist
auf google drive ich glaube nicht dass google drive morgen abkackt und wenn dann sind das
nur alte words weil es geht das natürlich eine gute begründung dann sollten wir das
machen ok leute wir sehen uns morgen wir sehen uns morgen früh wieder dann noch nicht so
aus aufgewacht weil aufwacht stream was benutzt um deine vms zu hausen das hier ist vor allem
wir workstation was hier lokal habe vor allem wir workstation ein offiziell erworbenes
gekauftes vmw workstation
gut leute wir sehen uns bis morgen